[музика]
Щиро вітаємо вас із брюсселя столиці
Бельгії та Євросоюзу
Саме тут вирішується майбутнє ЄС як
забезпечити рівний розвиток і
процвітання для всіх 20-7 країн-членів
про це поговоримо у сьогоднішньому
спецвипуску У фокусі Європи почнемо
прямо тут у Брюсселі центр міста та
європейські квартал процвітаючи та
заможні на противагу цьому прямо по
сусідству панує бідність ми
познайомилися з молодою жінкою з
неблагополучного району моленбек котра
сповнена рішучості розірвати Це замкнене
коло бідності
у хінде є мріє 20-річна дівчина хоче
зробити щось велике і стати успішною
хінде родом з molangbeca району брюсселя
відомого своєю яскравою
мультикультурністю але водночас низькими
доходами злочинністю та безробіттям
[музика]
але хінди має інші плани на майбутнє
я бачу довколо себе багато екранів
ти на Таймс сквер
himd мрія про роботу у нью-йорку усі
уважно слухають дівчина бере участь у
тренінгу з працевлаштування Артур ворк
організація має на меті допомогти
молодим людям із неблагополучних районів
брюсселя
до цього я була досить розгубленою не
мала жодних орієнтирів я не знала що
робити зі своїм життям так у мене були
цілі але я не знала як їх досягти
[музика]
хінде не самотня багато хто стикається з
нестачею перспектив У моленбеку більш
ніж кожен п'ятий безробітний А ті хто
знаходить роботу часто отримують низьку
зарплатню це разів чи контраст із іншими
частинами міста зрештою Брюссель це
де-факто столиця ЄС його Європейський
квартал це зовсім інший світ на кращих
робочих місцях у ЄС за місяць платять
стільки скільки люди у рідному районі
хінде заробляють за рік
у Брюсселі існує велика різниця між
багатими і бідними районами цей Регіони
з великим рівнем бідності
третина населення брюсселя живе на дохід
нижче рівня які вважаються межею
бідності
якщо ви виросли в таких районах вам дуже
важко отримати доступ до ринку праці і з
освітою Тут також серйозні проблеми
Щоб покращити ситуацію ЄС підтримує такі
проекти як Артур
хінди не закінчила школу перш ніж
приєднатися до артворк Вона переходила з
одного підробітку на інший
якийсь момент я зрозуміла що це не те
життя якого я хочу
учасники приходять щодня протягом 6
тижнів і вчаться основам робочого
процесу наприклад писати супровідні
листи та резюме але цілі програми вищі
розвиток особистості - це велика частина
нашої роботи він допомагає нашим
учасникам усвідомити що є тільки одна
людина здатна змінити їхнє життя на
краще вони самі
[оплески]
еркан один із таких людей арт-ворк
допоміг йому знайти роботу на
будівництві він не закінчив школу і
довго шукав своє місце у суспільстві
я можу нормально спілкуватися з іншими
людьми і краще розумію ринок праці
я прокидаюся вранці і більше не кажу
собі і я втомився я зосереджуюсь на
позитиві Я кажу собі я роблю свій внесок
я соціалізуюся я йду на роботу
[музика]
сьогодні важливий день для хінде після 6
тижнів навчання вона презентує те чому
навчилася і свої плани на майбутнє
її мати теж прийшла
Коли я прийшла сюди це було ніби вийти з
якої з темної печери
я так пишаюся нею люди які тут зібралися
допомогли їй рухатися вперед у житті
вона знайшла свій шлях
їм де може повернутися до школи коли
вона отримає атестат то матиме все
необхідне для свого майбутнього
Я хочу бути соціальною працівницею Я
хочу допомагати молодим людям
супроводжувати їх у тому через що мені
довелося пройти самі Я хочу мотивувати
їх і говорити їм жестя може бути не
завжди легким але ми можемо все змінити
перетворити негатив на позитив
і для
[музика]
незабаром хім де зможе зробити свій
внесок у подолання соціальної нерівності
у Брюсселі
[музика]
тут у цій будівлі де знаходиться
єврокомісія приймаються рішення які
впливають на таких людей як хінде її
професійна підготовка часто
фінансувалася через головну інвестиційну
політику ЄС політику згуртованості Вона
підтримує економічне зростання та
покращення якості життя громадян ЄС
серед іншого давайте детальніше
Розглянемо як це працює
ЄС витрачає багато грошей на те про що
більшість людей можливо ніколи не чули
політику згуртування ЄС
[музика]
політика згуртування Ні ніколи не чув
про це Ні
не чула про таке
[музика]
на неї йде третина бюджетних коштів ЄС
її мета полягає у тому щоб усі регіони
ЄС мали однакові шанси на розвиток і
жоден регіон не відставав щоб боротися з
нерівністю і сприяти згуртованості
Євросоюз називається клеєм який тримає
її разом
[музика]
основні питання довкілля транспорт
цифровізація підтримки малого та
середнього бізнесу соціальні та
культурні проекти
[музика]
політика згуртовності схожа на
восьминога Головне управління фондами
знаходиться у Брюсселі але багато рішень
приймаються на регіональному рівні однак
критики кажуть що не всі регіони
отримують однакову вигоду кошти не
завжди інвестуються розумно і немає
достатньої прозорості А ви знали що цей
парк був профінансований через
європейську політику згуртованості Ні я
не знала ні ні
якщо чесно ні не знала
користуючись новою велодоріжкою
переробляючи сміття їдучи потягом чи
просто дихаючи чистим повітрям багато
громадян ЄС навіть не здогадується Куди
йдуть гроші з політики згуртованості
[музика]
політика згуртованості також спрямована
на створення більш сталої та зеленої
Європи тут у Брюсселі обговорюються такі
теми як Кліматичні зміни в структурно
слабких регіонах ЄС Грецький острів тіло
з повністю живиться за рахунок чистої
енергії проект який привернув увагу
сусідніх островів
коли у неї є час вона приходить сюди щоб
подивитися на свою вітряну турбіну
міська голова Марія кама аліфері та
мешканці острова тілос довго і
наполегливо виборювали свою гігантську
споруду тепер вони її мають вітряк
заввишки 80 метрів і вагою кілька тонн
перетворив тіло на перший енергетичну
самодостатній острів у всьому
Середземномор'я
Ми дали зрозуміти що навіть на таких
маленьких островах можуть відбуватися
дуже великі речі
[музика]
коли вітер Іноді вщухає на допомогу
приходить сонячна енергія яку виробляє
ця електростанція десятки потужних
панелей збирають енергію приблизно 300
сонячних днів на рік Василь
калаврузіотісу потрібно приходити і
перевіряти їх лише раз на рік
Таким чином ми можемо мінімізувати
витрати на технічну обслуговування і в
той самий час ми можемо збільшити термін
служби фотоелектричних панелей до 25
років
[музика]
сотні жителів острова а також до 40
тисяч сезонних відвідувачів які
приїжджають на острів забезпечуються
відновлюваною енергією завдяки цьому
туризм основне джерело доходить тіло сам
до локальної зеленої енергетичної
Революції Були постійні труднощі
розповідає власник тавернень
михайлівську уракіс
раніше було досить важко електроенергія
часто вимикалася на кілька годин це
призводило до проблем із побутовими
приладами особливо з холодильниками із
продуктами харчування фінансові збитки
були доволі великими зараз все набагато
краще
тоді проблема була пов'язана із
дизельною електростанцією на острові кос
що за 50 кілометрів на північ Вона
виробляє електроенергію не завжди
надійно і з великою кількістю
забруднюючих речовин
станція виглядає жахливо а люди мабуть
досі купаються біля неї
щоб змінити це Марія та її команда
почали працювати над багатомільйонним
екопроектом який фінансується із фондів
ЄС документація для брюсселя тепер
займає багато папок але Марія ніколи не
думала здаватися
острову потрібен цей проект ми
відчуваємо що повинні зробити щось для
захисту довкілля я була переконана що ця
станція змінить ситуацію і не думає що
помилилась
і Їм це вдалося ось уже кілька років
вітрувата Сонячна електростанції
працюють керуються з цього контейнера і
відстежуються за допомогою ноутбука
Зараз ми бачимо що вітрогенератор
виробляє близько 600 кВт
і також важливо бачити що щодня ми
можемо не хати Близько трьох тон викидів
СО2
[музика]
навіть туристи знають що тілос у
буквальному сенсі слова має хорошу
енергетику
ми любимо острів особливо коли він стає
екологічнішим
Я думаю що Це фантастично тому
Швеції і інших туристичних країн
якби лише не ці старі лінії
електропередач вироблена тут енергія
досі подається у слабку державну
електромережу це дратує Марію
[музика]
тут де кабель виходить із моря завжди є
проблеми
іноді це волога іноді пил
одного разу тут навіть сталась пожежа і
весь острів поринув у темряву
тож компанія за зелену енергію триває
потрібно нова електромережа І тут на
тілосі переконані що їм це вдасться
[музика]
ключовий елемент побудови екологічно
чистої Європи рідкоземельні мінерали рід
вітрових турбін на цілості до
електромобілів і сонячних панелей
рідкоземельні мінерали важливий
компонент Ось чому мільйони коштів ЄС
вливаються в Естонію для будівництва
заводу для отримання рідкоземельних
металів
Та не борошно і не цукор це сировина яка
може втілити в реальність європейське
бачення зеленого майбутнього
рідкоземельні мінерали на цьому заводі
на сході Естонії розщеплюють на хімічні
компоненти
канадський інвестор хоче використовувати
цінні метали для виготовлення магнітів у
цьому процесі він покладається на ЄС
Протягом останнього десятиліття політики
в Брюсселі вивчали залежність від
ланцюжків постачання критично важливих
мінералів і вони визначили що ми
знаходимося на вершині індексу
критичності стратичних матеріалів для
зелених технологій та переходу до
промисловості з нульовим рівнем викидів
попит на рідко земельні метали зараз
дуже високий вони потрібні для
виготовлення високоефективних вітрових
турбін та двигунів для електромобілів
Цей білий порошок переробляються з
отриманого матеріалу виготовляють так
звані постійні магніти
і це почне відбуватися тут у
прикордонному місці нарва канадська
компанія необудує перший в Європі заводи
з виробництва таких магнітів за
мільйонної підтримки ЄС
вони будуть відповідати специфікаціям
електродвигунів для електромобілів
німецьких і французьких автовиробників
дотепер на ринку рідкоземельних
елементів та продуктів із них домінував
Китай
проєкту нарві покликаний це змінити
рукостискання з канадської промисловістю
відбулося в дуже вдалий момент для мера
цього прикордонного міста Цей завод може
допомогти краще інтегрувати російських
мешканців нарви в естонське суспільство
90% мешканців нарви мають російське
походження російське місто івангород
розташоване на протилежному березі річки
нарва
9 травня сотні глядачів зібралися на
березі Естонської річки коли через неї
було встановлено екран і з російською
пропагандою на демонстрантів які
виступали проти війни в Україні було
скоєно напад
[музика]
міський голова все що розраховує на
лояльність російськомовних мешканців
ніхто не хоче покидати Нарву та ЄС
але всі хотіли б кращого життя коли
будуть робочі місця коли люди підуть на
роботу місто оживе
але мало хто в нарві вірить обіцянкам
політиків
рівень безробіття в цьому прикордонному
регіоні більш ніж удвічі перевищує
середній по країні
занадто мало інвестицій багато хто
виїжджає бо немає роботи робота є але
хто хоче працювати за 800 чи 1000 євро
ви ж бачили ціну в магазинах
звісно Ми хочемо більше заводів це
створює робочі місця для наших чоловіків
щоб вони не виїжджали
є справне запобігти цьому тому гроші
продовжуватимуть надходити в цей
напружений естонсько-російській
прикордонний регіон
ну в процесі мета також полягає в тому
що місцеве населення побачило різницю і
безумовно коли ви гуляєте В нарві чи
сіла м ви вже бачите величезну роботу
яка була проведена за рахунок різних
регіональних фондів
фінансування ЄС - це не просто
інвестиція в Мирне майбутнє адже НАТО і
Росія стикається тут одне з одним на тлі
все більше і напруженості Є надія що
запланований магнітний завод принесе
робочі місця та процвітання і полегшить
ситуацію принаймні на естонському боці і
зробить свій внесок у зелене майбутнє
Європи
[музика]
у парку міні Європа в Брюсселі
відвідувачі можуть побачити найвідоміші
пам'ятки Європи включаючи копії
Ейфелевої вежі та тріумфальної арки Тут
також представлена Угорщина країна чий
лідер часто розходиться у поглядах із ЄС
Віктор Орбан та його уряд неодноразово
не дотримувалися основних цінностей та
принципів ЄС і все ж Угорщина
користується субсидіями зі скарбниці
Євросоюзу куди ж ведуть ці взаємини
[музика]
здається неймовірним що сюди у цю
глушину у будь-якої миті може прибути
потяг
значна частина цих шести кілометрів
колії через угорські луги і пасовища
була профінансована за рахунок коштів
Європейського Союзу
опозиційний політик також хатгаззі
зовсім не радіє поїстів у яку він
вирушає зради нас
далі
фінансування Європейського Союзу іноді
витрачається на корисні речі але Часто
воно використовується на щось абсолютно
непотрібне як наприклад ця залізниця
потяг проїжджає через рідне село пана
Віктора Орбана
[оплески]
на борту мало пасажирів це виглядає як
іграшка для прем'єр-міністра
мир неохоче спілкується з нами які
більшість мешканців але молода жінка і
сільської крамниці підходить до нас
чи вдячна Вона за проекти ЄС аж ніяк
безумовно ми можемо прожити без ЄС
зрештою є ж країни не члени Євросоюзу
маленький потяг це лише один приклад
того як європейська фінансова підтримка
використовується тут в Угорщині
на противагу цьому тут вона була
корисною але ймовірно не буде доступною
у майбутньому
у столиці Угорщини Будапешті за гроші ЄС
було модернізовано лінію метрополітену
чи отримують вигоду інші транспортні
лінії поки що невідомо
хоча Угорщина завжди була популярною
серед туристів посадові особи у ЄС не
так сильно люблять цю країну
це пов'язано з паном орбаном
нон-конформістом коли це стосується ЄС
особливо у питаннях лгбтк+ свободи слова
та системи правосуддя саме тому Брюссель
зупинив потік грошей за деякими
програмами фінансування поки Urban не
повернеться на правильний шлях
заступник мера Будапешта і відкрити
опонент Орбана карта каже що це може
зайняти деякий час
[музика]
[оплески]
у цій війні між угорським урядом і
брюселем найбільше програють жителі
Будапешта
тому що ми використовуємо ці гроші
відповідно до європейських цілей
поки що нових надходжень від ЄС не
очікується але все ж половина опитаних
підтримують Орбана і його політику на
вулицях його опоненти не бояться
говорити про суперечки і з ЄС
це ви на уряду
вони нехтують принципами Європейського
союзу а потім кричать що ми не отримуємо
грошей
треба поважати цінності Європейського
Союзу
важливо скільки людей не люблять уряд
Орбана
а вони
зробили
представнику європарламенті від партії
Орбана фідес та марш дощ заявив що у
заморожуванні фінансування винен лише ЄС
що стосується Угорщини то це відвертої
політичний шантаж
дістає політичною боротьбою за
владуження фінансування ЄС на розвиток
спрямований на створення тиску щоб
змінити позицію Угорщини
опозиційний політик акус хатгаззі
практично без успішно бореться з
популістською пропагандою Орбана
тим часом Він покинув маленький потяг і
їде по шосе мережа автомагістралей в
Угорщині управляється консорціумом тісно
пов'язаним із другом Орбана деякі
ділянки були профінансовані за гроші ЄС
очевидно для цього є достатньо хороший
для урбана
[оплески]
він натякнув що Європейський союз нам
буде потрібен лише тоді коли сюди
почнуть надходити гроші
він також сказав що Як тільки ми будемо
віддавати їм більше грошей ніж отримуємо
ми повинні почати тоді думати про те чи
залишимося ми в Європейському Союзі
[музика]
кошти ЄС можливо були витрачені на деякі
сумнівні проекти а там де гроші потрібні
вони можуть взагалі не надійти Схоже що
Угорщина ймовірно зайшла у глухий кут у
своїх взаєминах із Європейським Союзом
тут у брюссельському музеї музичних
інструментів представлені давні музичні
традиції Європи і їхня колекція вражає
своєю різноманітністю наприклад у
фінському місті калу стінин особливий
стиль гри на скрипці було внесено до
списку культурної спадщини Юнеско і
молоді музиканти відіграють кульшову
роль у збереженні цієї спадщини
каустінен у центральній Фінляндії Нічого
особливого ви можете подумати Але в
цьому скромному регіоні є дещо більше
ніж здається на перший погляд
[музика]
вечірня розвага шалена гра на скрипці ця
весела музична традиція відома далеко за
межами каустіна вона навіть популярна
серед місцевої молоді
[музика]
16-річний еркі звичайний підліток який
проводить багато часу за ноутбуком і
грає на гітарі але його головне
захоплення скрипка
щоразу коли я хочу пограти на скрипці в
школі чи ще десь мої друзі кажуть О
ні-ні не роби цього будь ласка не роби
цього Але я думаю що зараз це нормально
для моїх друзів що я слухаю і граю
народну музику
приєднуються до лав фольклорних
Ентузіастів каустіна на тиждень
інтенсивних репетицій вхід вільний для
всіх запрошують навіть наймолодших
фанатів гри на скрипці
на фестиваль З'їжджаються учасники з
усієї Фінляндії
незважаючи на те що репетиції тривають
довго діти знову беруться за інструменти
коли повертаються додому увечері а вони
просто продовжують практикуватись
у багатьох місцях традиційна скрипка
вимирає але не в каусті на ні
й
калущина не мав такої репутації і всіх
цих заходів пов'язаних з музикою
спадщиною народними танцями та
фестивалями ситуація була б зовсім іншою
народна музика це насправді музика
майбутнього
але арки також цікавиться минулим його
73-річний дідусь знає все про історію
каустиненської скрипки та її унікальний
ритм
його батько теж був музикантом
тоді грали на літніх весіллях які могли
тривати щонайменше цілий день а іноді 3
саме такі історії збирають дослідників
культури з усієї Північної Європи У
рамках проекту ЄС
жива спадщина - це те що продовжує
розвиватися і використовуватись якщо
щось зберігається в архіві то це вже
нежива спадщина це просто Музейна
пам'ятка
[оплески]
одне з тих місць які зберігають спадщину
Фінляндії живою
прощальник концерт проходить На ура
це найкращий спосіб весело провести час
разом
[музика]
[оплески]
заслужені Оплески молодим музикантам за
те що вони продовжують свою культурну
спадщину це лише один із багатьох
проектів розвитку що проводиться в
країнах ЄС на цьому наш спецвипуски з
Брюсселі завершується Дякуємо за
компанію і до зустрічі
[музика]